souvenez vous on vous avait reçu dans le
cadre du grand débat national et vous
aviez sélectionné cette proposition
venant de notre père qui n'avait pas
sélectionné
nous les avions collectivement
sélectionnés et les téléspectateurs
avaient voté exactement le principe
alors sa sympathie c'est alors regarde
mais moi ce que je propose à les lycées
voilà donc et on voit la régie va
bientôt aller dormir
voilà non on les angoisses à ce que
franchement il faut beaucoup beaucoup ça
fait six heures qui sont directement à
coucher à minuit les minutes rang 4
j'étais alors chilienne alors là bas
donc sourire carnassier
alors la tva à taux zéro sur les
produits de première nécessité augmenté
de 2 à 4 % le budget des hôpitaux le
retour de l'usf remise à plat examen de
l'unité de toutes les niches fiscales la
peine de prison pour les fraudeurs
fiscaux c'est lé 7 qui était arrivé en
tête un domaine aux téléspectateurs
seulement le crédit d'impôt pour la
compétitivité et donc les voir venir
narguer les vôtres et pme revoir les
cycles vauvert de la famille zorra par
les reprendre j'en suis à 4
sinon juste marlène schiappa oui dit la
vérité
alors on dit pas que j'en dis pas que ça
a servi à rien mais parce qu'il ya eu un
débat on a vu les priorités des français
enfin et des gens qui nous regardent un
grand panel de deux personnes mine de
rien il n'ya rien n'y a rien eu de fait
là c'est vrai mais je voudrais préciser
plusieurs éléments en toute sincérité
d'abord quand je suis venu pour ce grand
débat est gelée dire si on reprend tous
les extraits j'ai dit moi je viens d'en
balances ton peuple tu as déjà l'époque
et depuis le messager et surtout à
l'époque le présent la république a
lancé un grand débat et on voyait qu'il
ya des personnes qui ne saisissez pas de
ce grand débat qu'ils adorent c'est
compliqué c'est pas pour moi etc et vous
avez très gentiment accepter qu'on
puisse faire un grand débat officiel sur
le plateau de balances ton post qui a
d'ailleurs été enregistrés et
comptabilisé officiellement comme un
atelier du grand débat labellisé par le
comité d'experts du grand débat et
l'idée c'était de montrer aux gens qui
regardent que c'est facile de lancer un
grand débat et de débattre entre nous et
moi j'ai toujours dit je ne me prononce
sur aucune de ses propositions
j'en prends note elles sont enregistrées
et ensuite le gouvernement rend des
arbitrages en revanche j'avais pris un
engagement et cet engagement je les
tenues puisqu'on avait proposé à cette
occasion créé une brigade anti
discrimination elle a été lancée il ya
environ six mois avec des partenaires
des associations il y a désormais une
brigade anti discrimination idée qui
vient du plateau de balance des risques
c'est un très bel exercice que nous
avions fait à l'époque parce qu'ils
effectuent un mince je me souviens
madame la ministre je suis pas quelqu'un
qui jette des fleurs comme ça
gratuitement qui cirent les pompes mais
vous étiez peut exprimer
vous aviez joué un peu la maîtresse
d'école en tendant le feutre au tableau
et c'était vraiment les citoyens et on
était dans un débat et on avait un
certain nombre de propositions
ce qui est vrai et ce qu'il faut dire
parce que nos concitoyens
qu'on soit de droite de gauche du centre
hamon il faut dire aussi des vérités
madame chapeau et secrétaire d'état en
charge d'un dossier d'un sujet elle
n'est pas premier ministre elle n'est
pas prise en art public donc quand on le
prend nos propositions dans cet exercice
qui était un bel exercice et qu'elle les
porte au gouvernement elle n'est pas
décisionnaire je dire qu'on fera rien
non parce qu'elle ignore c'est une
localité non de la brigade antigang et
nos divisions mais comme dit cyril la
brigade anti discrimination qui relève
de ses prérogatives a été créé donc on
peut dire que pour ce qui la concerne à
la respectent effectivement les règles
du regain des bas et elle a fait plus
que portait la proposition au sein de
son ministère elle la mise en oeuvre en
revanche pour le reste c'est un peu plus
comme juste marlène schiappa pour avoir
un petit peu les coulisses des
téléspectateurs pulse à bord si vous
êtes vraiment arrivé avec vos cette
proposition qui sont sortis de
l'émission et vous êtes arrivé avec
edouard philippe vous l'avez dit voilà
les sept propositions
il vous a dit quoi alors d'abord vous
savez cette émission elle a été
extraordinairement regarder et il ya des
gens qui m'en parlent encore qui m'en
ont parlé encore récemment en saluant l'
exercice de démocratie qui a été menée
parce qu'il faut dire qu'on a été
extrêmement critique et et vous et moi
avant que cette émission ait lieu parce
qu'on allait la faire de la politique
lespwa sur un plateau c'était l'époque
aux balances ton post été critiquée
maintenant les autres chaînes savent que
je suis en fin de contrat avec ses 8 en
fin d'année ok donc ça en l'air
[Rires]
très bien en tout cas je vois là jeu
qu'est ce que j'étais en train de fils
d'or et améliore encore de connexion
d'ailleurs oui merci voilà oui vous me
demandiez si je n'avais portez merci
christian gélinas fatalisme oui j'ai
porté ces cette proposition mais au-delà
de ça vous savez je vous disais tout à
l'heure c'était un vrai débat enregistré
donc le comité d'experts du grand débat
en direct à rentrer ses propositions sur
le logiciel du grand débat et l on fait
partie officiellement de télé france et
qui nous regardent et vont se dire mine
de rien on a fait plein de propositions
n a pas une qui a été retenu on sert à
rien non pas du tout je pense que mother
qu'ils ont pris part au débat qu'il ya
un débat tulipes mais après dans la
démocratie pas part au débat et que mais
ses principes ses principes j'ai dépassé
moi vous savez quand je veux qu'on soit
émis des bons sinon alors où va renaître
les choses dû battre et des beaux-arts
net ok on va remettre les choses
d'équerré de migros le grand débat c'est
toi c'était millions de personnes qui se
sont exprimées
chaque personne arrive avec sa
proposition moi mon message c'était quoi
c'est à dire il n'y a pas de sous
citoyens et la politique ce n'est pas
réservé à une petite élite n'importe qui
qui est un citoyen qui n'a pas de
responsabilité politique ou médiatique
peut prendre part au grand débat
réfléchir et démontrer et d'ailleurs on
a vu des démonstration brillante pour
chacune de ces propositions j'ai
effectivement dû soit ne sera pas où on
voit bien vous dites oui on a pris part
au débat
et mine de rien ou du monde a servi à
rien non on n'a pas servi à rien parce
que grâce à cette émission il ya
beaucoup de gens tous fait leur propre
grand débat on a servi à créer la
brigade anti discrimination et ensuite
il ya des gens qui arbitre et la
démocratie c'est aussi ça et vous en
parlait assez souvent dans cette
émission
chacun s'exprime ensuite c'est un
présent la république qui a été élu qui
est prévu dans l'article pendant un
petit pendant la durée d'un mandat
le but est que j ai dit oui ou non non
mais y'a pas et il m'a dit oui mais vous
avez aussi est ce qu'après un petit
pincement au coeur marlène schiappa
quand même
wen un espoir dans cette émission on
était tous là on attendait on a créé
dans mes gars d'en dehors discrimination
comme ça
vous avez dit ça je m'en occupe je m'en
suis occupé de chiapa devant tout le
monde vous avez pris des risques et
c'est devant plusieurs personnes qui
vous critiquez vous êtes nous avait
vanté dans un esprit du temps
est-ce qu'il ya pas quand même un petit
pincement au coeur de vous dire qu'il
n'a pas une
sincèrement sincèrement il fut très fier
de ce qu'on a fait honnêtement parce
qu'il ya beaucoup de gens je veux dire
j'ai raconté tout à l'heure je suis allé
à l'onu à new york
c'est l'information je suis allé à l'onu
à new york on avait un petit peu de
temps on a marché dans la rue il ya une
bande de jeunes qui m'a interpellé deux
jeunes français qui étaient là en
vacances qui marchait ils m'ont en
plumetis est ce qu'on peut faire un seul
fille avec vous et discuté cinq minutes
chez oui bien sûr que vous aimez la
politique nous allons nous on n'aimait
pas du tout la politique on est fan de
cyril hanouna on regarde toutes ces
émissions très fort vous à vue et on
s'est concertés des français en vacances
on vous a vu dans cette émission et on a
commencé à s'intéresser à la politique
et je me dis mince si on a réussi à
intéresser des jeunes qui est éloigné de
la politique aux débats publics qui sont
illégitimes pour participer à ce débat
peut-être plus tard mais pour candidater
je sais quoi faut que l'on arrive à un
gouvernement c'est qu'on a réussi deux
coups n'avait pas tapé à côté parce que
vous avez besoin d'un ministre à il ya
deux propositions - qui sont remontés à
la surface par la manifestation prenait
sur ces deux corporations qui ont
manifesté un malaise les mois qui ont
suivi le débat qui sont sortis dans la
rue pour expliquer qu'elle vivait
l'exercice de leurs fonctions de manière
et la viande table pleine de souffrance
et donc effectivement la proposition de
et la proposition 6 au moins je pense
que le gouvernement a fait des erreurs
ne pas les prendre en considération mais
vous n'y pouvez rien que bernard deck et
peut-être que certaines les reprendront
pour les futures élections
ça n'a pas servi à rien je crois pas à
la cia pas se présente aux prochaines
élections président ce cheval septe